I had a lovely time hell yeah sure I'm
glad you did you're you're alright don't
look it's late
will I see you tomorrow no not tomorrow
some of us fellas are going to the drag
races over the weekend but I'll call you
sometime when I get back fine I'll be
waiting well we see
Lance yes mother
oh I guess I must have dozed off I was
just going to rest my eyes for a minute
what time is it oh it's it's just a
little after 11:00 you're home early
everything all right Oh perfect
I don't can't believe it mom he took me
to the country club
imagine me dancing at the Country Club
with Hal Grover I wish you could have
been there mom they even had a combo
thanks mom
thanks for making me this dream
I know you should have spent the time
sewing for your customers but the dress
was exactly right
I didn't feel a bit out of place well
when I sew for house mother and her
friends I see the kind of dresses they
wear and I just I I know how was
impressed and I think that's why he took
me to the country club he wanted to show
me off he likes me mother I just know he
likes me a lot
well band dear what the dress cost was
worth it unfortunately the final cost of
the dress has not been counted the price
that Lynn Cohen must pay will be a high
one
the dress like many other things in
today's world is part of an enormous
subtle pressure which our times put upon
young people evidence of the pressure is
plentiful almost anywhere you go
evidence of the worship of sex appeal as
if it were a final essence of
personality who is to blame if young
people respond to this pressure
reenacting in the privacy of parked cars
a theme hurled at them from every side
who is to blame if they respond to what
an anxiety ridden world seems to be
telling them dance faster little
children
whatever
the lyrics in the shadowy rule may be
suggestive but at that they suggest
something more human than most of the
headlines around the spinning globe
Oh
to the wall
Oh baby won't stick
faster faster faster faster ways to live
while you may
and a part of a frenzy to experience to
learn about everything takes hell Grover
and his friends to another part of the
state to participate in the weekend
meeting of drag racers from all over the
area
but drag-racing is not the only
amusement a city has to offer
No
it's alright
ah please won't think
don't be real
how much longer they going to be think
how to find some other place besides our
room and I'm tired I want to go to bed
howling he's rude Oh finally
yeah yes do
well don't even have to take her back
where you found her as she doesn't even
saw besides she has to go home alone her
purse this pricks kind they don't allow
to go out with boys she can go home and
tell her without meeting a new
girlfriend when I turned up the 3rd case
of primary syphilis in ten days
I knew Oakdale was up against it I don't
mind saying I was amazed I've been out
of medical school for 15 years and
haven't seen a handful of cases and now
three of them in 10 days and I'm not the
only doctor in town reporting cases that
looks like a real outbreak well that's
for sure and from the reports you and
the other doctors of sent us one that's
pretty well confined to kids from 12 to
19 years old
what's more it's too big for a Health
Department this size to handle on our
own
that's one reason we've asked for
assistance from the State Health
Department
they're sending as John Kent who is
especially trained for this work mrs.
Elliot has been interviewing the
patients you and the other doctors have
sent us but you can only do so much a
public health nurse has a lot of other
duties hello well hi John we were just
talking about you you know mrs. Elliott
this is dr. Jameson president of the
County Medical Society doctor this is
John can
he's field representative from the
venereal disease program mr. Kemp we
have a lot of work to do every doctor in
Oakdale has a lot of work to do
including dr. Sam Holden dr. Sam to
those patients who have known him for
many years
why hello Lin I'm glad to see you since
we got you through the time salida stage
I haven't had much chance to keep
acquainted I don't think I'm really sick
now dr. Sam but this stuff is a nuisance
and I just as soon be rid of it all
right let's find out about this stuff
well it's of breaking out I tried to
hide it with makeup but it it's all over
me mother thought it might be the
three-day measles but I may have had
them well let me call the nurse and
we'll check you over miss Daley would
you come in please Hey well dr. Sam what
do you think it is could be a number of
things maybe an allergy to some food and
writing you a prescription that may help
you use this for a couple of days and
let me know if there's no change okay I
will I feel better already now that
there's something I can do about it well
bye Oh goodbye Lin give my regards to
your mother
it could be an allergic reaction that
rash isn't entirely typical
it looks like syphilis live Cory it
couldn't be
now hold on Sam you're a doctor you know
VD doesn't play favorites just because
you brought that girl into the world and
have taken care of her all our life
doesn't make her immune why didn't you
take a blood test because it just
couldn't be as doctors are human so
there maybe in their hearts the wish
that some things just couldn't be but as
doctors are men of science dedicated to
the welfare of all their fellow beings
that wish must give way to a review of
the facts and the facts leave no room
for a wishful thinking in the long years
of his practice dr. Sam is too often
seen the final tragedy of latent
untreated syphilis he has seen those
whose minds were destroyed whose bodies
were horribly crippled and he has seen
helpless babies born of syphilitic
mothers the most tragic victims of all
what dr. Sam knows only too well wipes
out every trace of his momentary wish
that such things couldn't be where Lynne
Corwin is concerned especially with
Lynne Coleman one of his children such
things must not be
syphilis can be cured and if regrettably
Lynn has syphilis
she must be cured Lynn this is dr. Sam I
think maybe better as Lynn Cohen makes
an appointment with dr. Sam other
doctors have sent in young people whose
disease has already been diagnosed for
appointments with John Kemp the field
representative John camps job is not an
easy one nobody wants to hear what he
must tell those he interviews and nobody
wants to tell him what he must find out
for syphilis can be halted only if
everyone involved is located and
examined with the approval of their
personal physicians John camp interviews
every patient diagnosed as having
syphilis to learn the names of all those
with whom the patient has had sexual
intercourse I appreciate you bringing
your daughter down the genetic the
interview is confidential though so if
you'll just take a seat in the hall yeah
I have a seat Mahal I just brought her
in to see if you could get it out of her
I can't find out what kind of trash
she's been wrong with please take a seat
in the hall mr. net oh I'm leaving go
welcome to her she's no daughter of mine
the parents of teenagers who have
blundered blindly into infection are
sometimes more blind than the children
they condemn John camp is all too
familiar with typical parental reactions
it's that sex education they get in the
school if my boy hadn't known about such
filthy things he wouldn't have got
curious and he wouldn't be sick
I didn't want him to find out not me nor
his daddy told him nothing but some
other busybody is dead oh I'm surprised
all right but only that he had the guts
to do it
he's a biggest penny waste I oversaw but
I sowed my Wild Oats when I was a boy
but I didn't think that kid of mine had
it in him look I'm not gonna preach it
him it's a church's job to preach my
husband an oath tell you it's not
juniors fault it's all his fault I just
can't do a thing with him anymore
confronted with those who have been
judged who come to him even under the
best of circumstances ashamed and afraid
John camp acts neither as judge nor
prosecutor he is an investigator dealing
with the facts no you didn't get
syphilis from a toilet seat bill you got
it from sexual intercourse with somebody
who had it now these are the people that
we have to talk about for their
protection as well as for yours
nobody wants to talk but because John
camp sees beyond the patient to the
welfare of the whole community he must
make these youngsters realize their
responsibility all right bill now what
about your very best girl she there it
any I I haven't got a best girl you
wouldn't want to walk out of this room
with somebody's life in your hands would
you bill I know but she's all right bill
that's something a doctor has to decide
now her name is her name's Betty her
name is Mary
his name is Jack her name is Susan
Roberta
Bob Joanne the names are many and there
is usually more than one but the patient
must tell the names of all sexual
contacts within the infectious period if
the chain of infection is to be broken
what makes John camps job more difficult
and increases the danger to the
community is the fact that there is
sometimes no name at all all right tom
who else nobody just them just just them
and some girl at the ballpark I didn't
even catch her name where does she live
who knows it was a knife game we never
get out of the park well tell me what
she looked like anything you can
remember about her oh she was just a
pickup she may be the reason you're
sitting where you are now if she is I
wish I'd never laid eyes on her she
really gave me the come on and her foot
taller than me um she has sort of light
blonde hair starting with a known
hangout the ballpark with only a vague
description of a girl the field
representative tries to find one of the
known contacts of an infected person
and here as with all other cases in
Oakdale he is successful in locating a
potential source of syphilis not all
aggressive blood
unfortunately for other communities a
number of contacts remained in
surrounding towns locating a possibly
infected boyfriend and Ashton may be
simple
since Ashton is across a state line
another state health department is
alerted to find the boyfriend another
field representative continues the
search perhaps finding that in our
increasingly mobile society a search has
become more complicated the job of this
field representative now becomes one of
knocking on doors in the last known
neighborhood seeking clues asking
continuing to ask until he finds someone
who knows where the Farley's on Hagen's
or the Smiths have moved to California
to New Hampshire to Mexico the Oakdale
outbreak has spread its tentacles
nationwide crossed an international
boundary it is not and has not been from
the beginning Oak Dale's problem alone
syphilis is not only an individual
problem but a community problem as well
as Hal Grover's father is finding out I
always thought you were a good doctor
now I'm gonna find out if there's any
legal action that I can take it looks to
me like you're violating medical ethics
what a doctor treats a patient for is
nobody else's business but you had to
call him the whole Health Department
subjecting a boy to that kind of
questioning and those interviews are
confidential if you know what the boy
was ask it's because he told you as for
me I was following good medical practice
and obeying the law PD has to be
reported to the Health Department
protection of the public is more
important than the temporary
embarrassment to your boy him embarrass
his mother is sick with mortification
and I can't stand to look my friends in
the eyes whether they know what's
happened or not but he's not embarrassed
I told him I didn't even want to claim
him for a son
you know what he said
looked at me as boneless brass he said
you never did
I bought that boy everything in the
world he ever asked for
bicycles ponies car
he's got the best clothes
biggest allowance in town
more caning one
I don't know maybe once the thingy seems
to have been looking for pretty
desperately somebody who cares
I wasn't worried when she was out with
him he came from one of the best
families in town if it just wouldn't
make it harder for Lin I'd Hall how
Grover out in the town square and beat
him within an inch of his life
oh that might be the least of his
troubles
I believe Lin and I think you do too
when she says he was the only one it
isn't all House fault
I could have oh I just stopped to think
but I wanted him to like me mom said she
wasn't worried when I was out with him
but I was the one she couldn't trust I
was the one
Lynne is more fortunate than some to
have parents who will make the difficult
effort to understand but dr. Sam's
health Lynn : will be cured of the
physical disease although she may never
be free of its emotional consequences
the 50 or more young people who are
victims of the Oakdale outbreak will all
be cured either in the clinic of their
health department or by their personal
physicians the outbreak in Oakdale will
be over the local health department's
file marked clothes
somewhere in a city where a drag race
was held is one who was forgotten whose
name it was ever known was not reported
is this your town is this your daughter
is this your son
that's on little children